HEY, I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT BASEBALL EITHER ANTHONY
EDWARDS, BUT I KNOW WHO ALEX
RODRIGUEZ IS MAN. I THOUGHT I
WAS THE ONE ADULT MALE IN THE
COUNTRY THAT NEW THE ABSOLUTE
LEAST. THERE WAS TO KNOW
ABOUT AMERICA'S FORMER
PASTIME ANTHONY EDWARDS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I KNOW
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
BASEBALL THAN ANTHONY EDWARDS
BECAUSE I KNOW WHO ALEX
RODRIGUEZ IS FUTURE OWNER OF
THE MINNESOTA TIMBERWOLVES.
HEY, ANTHONY, YOU BETTER
FIGURE OUT WHO ALEX RODRIGUEZ
IS I WAS REALLY SURPRISED BY
I AM TOO. I MEAN JUST BECAUSE
LIKE YOU DON'T LIKE A RODS
LIKE ONE OF THOSE THE GUYS
THAT LIKE YOU DON'T NEED TO
KNOW A LOT ABOUT BASEBALL OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. LIKE IF
YOU LIKE MONEY YOU LIKE A ROD
RIGHT? I MEAN, COME ON.
NOBODY EVER EAT. HE'S THE
FIRST TO GET LIKE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACTS AND
HE GOT TWO OF THEM. SO AND
SAW EVERY PENNY OF EACH ONE
OF THEM. I MEAN, THAT'S
WHERE I WOULD THINK EVEN LIKE
THE YOUNG GUYS WHO MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN WATCHING BASEBALL
I REMEMBER WHEN HE WAS A VERY
VERY YOUNG SHORTSTOP OF
SEATTLE MARINERS BEFORE HE
JOINED THE YANKEES AND HE WAS
HITTING A LOT OF HOME RUNS.
AND YEAH, WE'RE KIND OF
CHANGING THE PERCEPTION THAT
POSITION AND THEN RIGHT WHEN
HE WENT TO THE YANKEES. THEY
MOVED HIM TO THIRD RIGHT?
THEY LOVE JERRY STATOR. SHUI.
IS THAT RIGHT? THAT'S RIGHT
LIKE TO PRESS THAT I KNOW
THAT MUCH. WELL, THAT'S OKAY.
IN THE HISTORY OF SPORTS. YOU
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THEM THE
NEW YORK YANKEES. THAT'S
RIGHT. WHAT'S YOUR RECORD
RIGHT NOW? ARE YOU
LOWING
I HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO IT YET.
IT'LL TAKE ME A FEW MONTHS
THE DRAFTS OVER. I'LL START
SITTING DOWN AND WATCHING
SOME YANKS A LITTLE BIT.
ALRIGHT, TODAY'S DRAFT
PLAYERS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
BE OWNERS OF NFL FRANCHISES
INSPIRED BY ANTHONY EDWARDS
NOT KNOWING WHO ALEX
RODRIGUEZ IS FUTURE OWNER THE
TIMBERWOLVES QUESTION FOR YOU,
GUESTS FROM JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO IS ONE OF ONLY
TWO RECEIVERS WITH A THOUSAND
OR MORE YARDS AFTER THE CATCH
OVER THE LAST TWO SEASONS
WHAT FAMILIAR RECEIVER IS
THE OTHER MORE THAN A
THOUSAND YARDS AFTER CATCH
OVER THE LAST TWO SEASONS
OVER A THOUSAND YARDS AFTER
THE CATCH.
IT'S THE LAST TWO SEASONS.
THAT'S LIKE OKAY, SO THAT
TOUGH THERE. I DON'T I'M
KAREN WITH THAT ONE. I KNOW
FAMILIAR RECEIVER. THAT'S
WHERE YOU GOT ME LIKE
THINKING LIKE, I DON'T THINK
THAT PART OF IT'S FAIR. I
DON'T I DON'T. YEAH THAT
THAT'S THAT'S PROBABLY GOING
TO SEND YOU OFF IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION THAN
WHERE YOU SHOULD BE GO. I
WILL IT'S LIKE FAMILIAR
RECEIVER IS LIKE, IS IT THE
SHOW A FRIEND OF THE SHOW OR
IS IT LIKE A GUY THAT WAS ON
HIS TEAM? THAT'S WHERE I'M
LIKE NOT SURE I'M GONNA GO
I'M GOING TO SAY STEFON
DIGGS.
IS IT THE GUY ON THIS TEAM?
IT'S COOPER CUP ALL THOSE
SLANTS SLANT SCIENCE THE
BOOTLEGS. ALL THAT STUFF,
RIGHT? YEP. DAMN IT. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT,
YOU KNOW, I JUST TELL HIM
PETER OR IN THE IN THE SHOW
DURING A BREAK THAT THE LIST
OF PLAYERS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE IS OWNERS TO ME IN MY
MIND IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
LIST OF PLAYERS. THAT WOULD
MAKE GOOD PROFESSIONAL
WRESTLER. YEAH. I AGREE. I
AGREE OVERLAP. I WANT A FUN
OWNER. I WALKED WRONG.
TO BE THE OWNER. I WANT GRONK
TO ME THE GUY WHO COMES INTO
A LOCKER ROOM BEFORE THE GAME.
I WANT GRONK DOING THE
PREGAME. SPEECH. I WANT GRONK
TO MAYBE SUIT UP ONCE IN A
WHILE. I WANT GRONK TO BE
THROWING AROUND THE CIGARS
AFTER THE VICTORY BECAUSE
SOME OF THEM MAY NOT CONTAIN
TOBACCO. I WANT GRONK TO BE
THE OWNER. THAT ONE'S EASY
FOR ME. ALL RIGHT EYES CLOSED
II HEAR YOU. I MEAN, YEAH, I
MEAN THE FIRST PICKS EASY FOR
ME TO I WANT AARON RODGERS
TO BE THE
GOTTA DO I WANT WHY YA CUZ I
LOVE AARON RODGERS. I THINK
ONE HE'D HAVE GREAT
PERSPECTIVE ON, YOU KNOW
WITH THE TEAM. HE'S SMART AS
HELL. WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ENJOY A FEW FINGERS AT
TEQUILA EVERY NOW AND THEN
AND DO STUFF LIKE THAT. YOU
KNOW, HE'S WITTY. HE MIGHT
QUIZ YOU A LITTLE BIT EVERY
NOW AND THEN WITH THE
JEOPARDY QUESTIONS. I'M IN
I'M TAKING AARON RODGERS.
HE DID MIGRATE TO TEQUILA
SPECIFICALLY AFTER THEY
TRADED UP TO GET JORDAN LOVE
LAST YEAR AND I GUARANTEE YOU
IF AARON RODGERS WAS THE
OWNER. THEY WOULD NEVER DRAFT
A QUARTERBACK IN ROUND ONE
WHILE THEY STILL HAVE ONE OF
THE GREAT QUARTERBACKS OF ALL
TIME READY TO GO. JUST
GET BACK TO THE SUPER BOWL NO
HELP GOTTEN WITH THAT PICK
LAST YEAR. I'LL GO PATRICK
MAHOMES AS MY SECOND PICK
PATRICK WERE HOMES ALREADY
HAS THAT VIBE AND SUCCESSFUL
QUARTERBACKS BECAUSE OF ALL
THE THINGS YOU HAVE TO DO
WITH SO MUCH MORE THAN BEING
ABLE TO THROW A FOOTBALL.
YOU ARE A LEADER. YOU ARE A
GUY WHO BECOMES THE FOCAL
POINT OF ATTENTION. YOU'VE
GOT TO THRIVE IN THAT
CRUCIBLE AND I THINK PATRICK
MY HOMES JUST LIKE PEYTON
MANNING TOM BRADY RUSSELL
RODGERS IN THERE PATRICK
MAHOMES IS A GUY WHO'S
ALREADY PROVEN TO ME IS GOING
HE DOES. SO IF PAT MAHOMES IS
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL EAMS
BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO BUST
HIS ASS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
IS, YOU KNOW, I MEAN AGREED
AGREED HE WAS HE WAS
DEFINITELY ON MY LIST.
LIST. YEAH, I MEAN THAT'S
IT'S HARD QUARTERBACKS ARE
HARD NOT TO PICK FOR THIS
EXERCISE TO A DEGREE. I'M
DEFINITELY A LITTLE BIASED
TOWARDS THEM BECAUSE THE THE
NEXT GUY I WANT TO GO IS THE
GUY YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT IS IS BRADY. YEAH.
BRADY WOULD BE MY NEXT CHOICE.
DEFINITELY. I MEAN AGAIN,
YOU KNOW SMART, YOU KNOW
CARES ABOUT PEOPLE CARES
ABOUT THE TEAM GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ADD THINGS LIKE THAT
AND HAS A GREAT WAY OF LIKE
YET CAN BE LIKE HEY COME IN
MY OFFICE AND YOU KNOW, LET'S
TALK ABOUT LIFE. I MEAN SEEN
IT ALL BEEN THERE DONE THAT
NOSE WILL PLAYERS LOOK LIKE
KNOWS HOW YOU SHOULD RUN AN
ORGANIZATION THROUGH
BELICHICK. I'LL GO WITH BRADY
IS MY SECOND PICK NOW THE
QUESTION IS WOULD HE HIRE
YOU TO BE THE EQUIPMENT MAN?
PROBABLY NOT YOU'RE GONNA
LEAD ME DOWN THAT ROAD, HUH
ON A THURSDAY, HUH? JUST
GOING TO START ME OFF ON A
SOCIAL-MEDIA WAR TO START MY
WEEKEND. HERE WE GO. I'M JUST
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT MADE
ME CURE KNOW HE'D
ONLY HIRE THE BALL BOYS HE
YOU KNOW, I'M INSPIRED THE
INCORRECT ANSWER THAT YOU
GAVE TO THE TRIVIA QUESTION
AS I'M SITTING HERE
RUMINATING ON THE POSSIBILITY
OF STEFON DIGGS IS THE OWNER
OF A FOOTBALL TEAM. THERE'S
JUST SOMETHING ABOUT STEFON
DIGGS. THERE'S A CHARISMA
THAT ISN'T IT INTO DURING
GAMES. IT'S OBVIOUS, BUT IT'S
MORE SUBTLE AWAY FROM THE
FIELD. I JUST I'D WANT TO
WORK FOR HIM. I JUST WANT TO
BE AROUND HIM. I WILL GET HIM
STROMBOLIS AT PAISANO'S
STEINBRENNER I JUST THINK
HE'S JUST TO EAT. HE'S COOL
SOAK UP RIGHT SO MUCH NATURAL
WISDOM THAT FLOWS THROUGH
STAPHON DIGS AND AND HE LOVES
TO WIN AND HATES TO LOSE.
YEAH, AND HE REALLY HATES TO
LOSE. SO THERE'D BE A HIGH
DEGREE OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE BUILDING AS WELL II LIKE
THAT I DO I THINK THERE'S
SOME RECEIVERS THAT YEAH ARE
ON MY LIST CERTAINLY THAT
I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT HERE WHERE
I'VE GONE LIKE, YEAH, THEY
GET IT. THEY'RE COOL. YOU
KNOW, THEY GOT DEFINITELY A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
LIFE IN SOME CASES.
REFRESHING AND INTERESTING.
SO OKAY. I'M NOT MAD AT YOU
THERE THAT ONE THAT ONE AT
ALL. I THINK THE LAST I I'M
GOING TO GO TO A DIFFERENT
ONE HERE. I'M GOING TO
ENDOWMENT CONCEALED. THAT'S
RIGHT. THAT'S THAT'S MY GUY.
I MEAN THE GUY STILL GETS HIS
ADVICE FROM WARREN BUFFETT ON
AS FAR AS HOW TO HANDLE HIS
ACUMEN. HE'S GOING TO KNOW
HOW TO DO THINGS THAT WAY AND
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT LIKE
COACHES AND PLAYERS BEING ON
THEIR TOES AND BEING ON THEIR
P'S AND Q'S WHEN THE OWNERS
WALKING THROUGH THE BUILDING.
ARE GOING TO BE READY
DEFINITELY BECAUSE I MEAN IF
HE YELLS YOU AND PUT YOU IN
YOUR PLACE, YOU'RE GOING TO
BE SCARED TO DEATH, YOU KNOW,
HE'S GOT A GREAT WAY OF NO
NONSENSE ABOUT HIM. LET'S GET
OUR WORK DONE THAT TYPE OF
ATTITUDE. I'LL GO WITH SUE IS
MY LAST ONE JUST GOT TO BE
CAREFUL WHEN HE COMES DOWN TO
THE SIDELINES DURING THE GAME.
DO THAT. YOU DON'T WANT TO
SEE THAT FOOT, YOU KNOW,
STICKING OUT TRIPPING
SOMEBODY THEY RUN BY NOT THAT
THAT HE STEP ON YOU. HE
WOULDN'T TRIP YOU. IT'S A
DIFFERENT. IT'S A DIFFERENT,
YOU KNOW.
NICO TOG